let me ask you if you're watching this
right now if you're watching this right
now what caused this this is my question
for you what causes we talked about this
uh earlier do you think media is the
cause of this
do you think the left is the cause of
this do you think
trump's the cause of this so meaning
media left
trump if it's uh uh if you think it's
trump
uh if you think it's media press thumbs
up if you think it's
the left push thumbs down if you think
it's trump comment on trump
comment section say trump i'm curious to
know who you think this was because
for us when you watch this i want to
know who is the number one
you know the domino you know you ever
seen the guys that put the domino in all
of someone one
you tip one 50 000 dominoes yeah
i want to know who was the first i don't
want to know the third
or the fifth or the second i want to
know what
caused things to go bam let me ask this
yeah because i want to understand where
your question is
what do you mean by is it the media is
it trump like clearly
this is on trump not conceding and then
the media runs with the fact that he was
not conceded what led to this what what
led to
yesterday yeah what led to this what led
to us being here
what would the media have to do with
that let me
i'm asking you a question yeah i wanna
know what i'm talking about buddy i mean
we just talked about that a minute ago i
gave you my explanation
why it's okay what what does this video
represent
what does yesterday represent what does
it represent
it represents united or divided divided
how did it become divided oh you're
going deeper deeper deeper deeper
what caused us to be divided i look at
my parents when they got a divorce
i asked what caused them to be divided
and i would sit there and i would watch
my mom's aunts [ __ ] about my dad and i
would watch my dad's mother
and brothers [ __ ] about my mom all the
time
so who created the division family
behind closed doors we're stoking both
of them oh
she's not doing this she's not a good
wife he's not a good husband he's not
finally they're like screw it man i'm
going to please my family they got a
divorce
yeah this stuff doesn't happen yeah
because of one day or one year caused
the division this has been four or five
years in the making maybe six or seven
it's the influx of social media it's
people being you know able to comment
and communicate about anything and take
sides and
forge enemies and go against each other
it's the media stoking the fire it's
trump
doing his part no doubt it's the far
left looking at an opportunity to take
advantage of this situation
it's a perfect toxic cocktail that came
to a boiling point yesterday and that's
what you got
you know i i appreciate what we're
saying here uh
and and clearly media being you know
dominated by
you know left center of left
uh people um but
the media has been around for 100 200
freaking years
the media has changed okay never
fundamentally it's not we've never had a
president like this
so we can i mean has the media changed
that much in four years
eight years 10 years 20 years yes it has
never been changed
why is it why has it changed so much
because you have trump calling
the media the enemy of the people it's
all fake news
so there's enough blame to go around no
doubt no doubt i'm not but you have to
look at the top and there's one person
out there that has caused
two majority of this you can't just say
trump you can't but you can't say
just so you know a lot of people agree a
lot of people commented saying trump
more commented agreeing saying it's the
media and fewer commented saying it's
the left
so number one so far right now is media
then it's a tie between left and trump
based on what i'm seeing with the
comment section a bunch of people
commented so
i i i don't know i i think i think so
here's my question for you
um i asked the guy yesterday i said so
how was uh cnn ms embassy being held
accountable for saying russia russia
russia for three years
how wasn't true they're not never
happened yeah we just had to move on so
so so so the guy that walked in on the
cop
what's gonna end up happening to him he
should be arrested should he be arrested
he's going down do you guys all agree
that he should be arrested
should he be arrested not just him but
everyone behind him too uh
fine what i'm trying to tell you is they
should be arrested right okay
fine if he gets arrested are you gonna
say oh my gosh you shouldn't arrested
that guy
are you gonna say that no okay um
trump got suspended from twitter
yesterday on facebook for 12 hours
right wrong move i'm good with that you
know he knows the rules at this point i
think it was the only thing they could
do right move around i think it's the
right
even right move right move to to slow it
down
right move to not entice right okay all
right
if he tries to do something they're just
gonna stomp him okay watch this but wait
a minute guys look where i'm going with
this this is my point i'm making to it
that guy should be held accountable yes
we all agree trump held accountable for
his tweets shut it down for 12 hours
yes how the hell is the media being held
accountable
zero who's getting fired who's getting
fined
who's getting shut down who's shutting
down cnn for 12 hours
who's shutting down msnbc for 12 hours
who's shutting down fox for 12 hours
how come they don't get a shutdown why
don't we get a shutdown for these guys
for 12 hours for one day
cnn is off fine advertisement's gone why
don't we do that to them you're talking
about accountability
there is no accountability for the media
what is you because they hide under the
opinion section
here's the news section yeah you're in
the opinion you're a journalist what is
the accountability
i'll tell you what i learned something
from you remember yesterday i said oh
there's a lady who got shot
and i heard she was 16 or something like
that you corrected and i said listen i i
made a mistake yeah apparently she was
not uh underage
i had some bad news i apologize i
retract my statement
but real news organizations have to
apologize when they make a mistake you
were in the media you understand that
right like well
when do you have to apologize but you
know what that ship has just sailed they
are just that's not what the media is
anymore here's here's an analogy i would
use over the last four five six years
this was a inferno yesterday but leading
up to that you had some people that
dried the grass around there you had
some people that brought some kindling
you got some people that brought some
logs you got some other people that you
know brought some loose paper
you got the media that poured fuel all
over this and then trump takes a lighter
boom or a match and it goes i mean
there's so many people that are
responsible for what happened yesterday
you cannot just say it's one entity or
one person but
it's where we're at as a country right
now and i hope we're smart enough to
figure it out
and move on and move past this a little
bit listen if you're running a company
and there is fraud internally
or there is a falling out
or there is a issue that all of a sudden
happens an event
like you know i was out of town once and
we had a a
issue that happened about a year and a
half ago two years ago
and i'm like what the hell happened
camera conversations everything we did
investigation we found out who it was we
had to
make a decision right and we made the
decision i bet that was scary for that
person
yeah to face you yeah but but the point
is the point is
i wanted to find out who started it not
who was involved if i come and slap you
in the face you're probably going to
react i'm not looking for the reaction
i want to know who inside who started
the whole thing
right i think the media needs to be held
accountable and unfortunately i don't
think
nothing's going to happen today how do
you hold the media if they don't ever
take them off with 24 hours he's taking
them off
oh dude suspend the media for 24 hours
who's responsible for that that has to
be from the top
fcc hang on a second hang on a second
how much is social media uh facing
backlash how much is social media facing
backlash right well they're talking
about breaking up facebook okay
all right well then how have you one two
three when have you heard anything being
held accountable for the other guys
i agree with you okay why no one's how
can you go up there and say how is adam
schiff being held accountable saying
russia 100 guaranteed to happen
how is he being held accountable he's
not well our comments like that
election i don't know yeah but but
that's great yeah
cnn is now facing real estate one
thought on that you know because i
there's fox either as msnbc
all over i just told you put all of them
in there i agree with your idea yeah
for sure put a fine here's let me ask
you guys i'm saying who knows is that
what the the government does
let me know how the government's gonna
start finding the media if they don't
like what they say that's a slippery
slope
i'm sorry i'm sorry in the nba what
happened to magic johnson when he tried
to recruit players away to the lakers
what happened to him
how big of a fine was it half a million
dollar fine
okay you can be doing it when he was
talking about hey paul george
he did this i think on jimmy kimmel's
show i don't know who was fallon or
kimmel one of those guys
he's like hey no i'm not going to try to
recruit paul george well you know if i
don't uh and i do one of these things
wait okay you guys tampering okay these
guys are tampering no problem fine
find them find find hannity
let's go through this let's go down this
rabbit hole who's doing the finding
the congress the president the same way
there is an associate there same way
there's an association the same way
there's a method to the madness
of accountability you do it the same way
these guys are making big dollars
if you're making big dollars hey you're
in the nba you say something to the
referee you're getting fined
it's just basic protocol if you ever say
anything to the ref what happens 35
grand 25 grand 50 grand
great it's a form of accountability and
then the players say
i wasn't going to say anything because
i'm not going to give my money up to the
association associated great
i like that it's a form of
accountability so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye